[Música]
buenas noches mi nombre es ana maría
saldarriaga
yo soy de medellín colombia y el día de
hoy quiero compartirles un concepto que
he venido trabajando por los últimos 8 o
10 años que es una recolección de
experiencias personales y profesionales
pero el cual también ha empezado a hacer
mucha investigación rigurosa
y para darles un contexto sobre todo de
medellín no sé ustedes qué tanta
historia tengan pero quiero que se
imaginen la ciudad más violenta del
planeta tierra
y quiero que sepan que medellín era eso
en la época en la que yo nací
y yo no vengo de una familia con muchos
recursos no soy una persona que se daba
el lujo de tener la seguridad de un
plato de comida en la mesa y por ende no
me podía dar el lujo de pensar en un
futuro mi lujo era llegar vivo al día
siguiente
pero tuve la fortuna de ver la
transformación de esa ciudad a medida
que yo también iba creciendo y
transformando en una mujer y esa
transformación de medellín hizo que en
menos de 30 años la ciudad pasará de ser
la más violenta del mundo a la más
innovadora ganándole a ciudades como
nueva york y tel aviv medellín en
latinoamérica ahora una de las mejores
ciudades para vivir en latinoamérica
y eso ha generado en mí muchas ilusiones
que se convirtieron en sueños y sueños
que se convirtieron en ideas de tal
forma que a mis 24 años tuve una
oportunidad de liderazgo sin igual no sé
ustedes que estaban haciendo a los 24
años pero yo estaba sentada en una mesa
siendo la líder de un equipo de 17
personas donde esta organización era
encargada de hacer intercambios
profesionales traer extranjeros y enviar
colombianas al exterior
y el gobierno de colombia lanzó una
convocatoria para traer profesores de
inglés a los colegios públicos de bogotá
para transformar el proceso de
aprendizaje que fuera aprendizaje de
calidad
obviamente las instituciones que aplican
a esas convocatorias tienen años de
experiencia y llegó yo y voy le digo mi
equipo equipo tenemos que hacerlo si
medellín fue capaz de transformarse
nosotros vamos a transformar la
educación de bogotá
y en el proceso no sabíamos cómo y
cuando empezamos a pedir ayuda de
personas mayores la respuesta siempre
fue no lo hagan es muy riesgoso
pero al final decidimos transformar esa
idea en una realidad y en el proceso lo
hicimos a pesar de que si no cumplíamos
al cien por ciento de ejecución
a mí me podría meter a la cárcel por
incumplimiento de contrato y nos podrían
cerrar la organización y dejarla sin
operaciones por más de cinco años con
sanciones financieras pero le metimos al
más sudor y sangre nuevamente todos
menos una vez de 30 y no solamente
logramos ejecutar el proyecto sino que
lo hicimos en tiempo récord trajimos a
más de 100 extranjeros a educar a esos
niños en inglés de verdad y el proyecto
fue tan exitoso que siguió en los años
venideros
24 años que hoy muchos después me llevan
a entender que este proceso de
transformación de ideas que este ejemplo
que yo les di no es único
tenemos muchas personas transformando
ideas en realidades
uno de ellos mis favoritos los
emprendedores los emprendedores son esas
máquinas que se juegan el todo por el
todo por una idea pero hay unas
estadísticas alarmantes que dicen
creadas por careerbuilder y sybase
insights que en una encuesta el 82% de
empresarios y personas de liderazgo
decían cree creen están seguras que
tenían la experiencia suficiente para
crear y mantener una empresa para crear
y mantener una idea pero cuando
empezaron a evaluar ya recolectar las
estadísticas se dieron cuenta de que
sólo uno de cada diez emprendimientos
logran tener más de 10 años de operación
y peor aún de esos pocos que lograron
tener 10 años de operación cuatro de
cada cinco seguidos y cofundadores no
terminaron su rol de liderazgo se
rindieron en el proceso
porque multiple múltiples factores
debilidades en sus habilidades técnicas
blandas
no lo sabemos o si la verdad es que si
es porque tenemos una claridad de
expectativas que todos creemos saber
para dónde vamos y cómo lo vamos a hacer
pero que en realidad se parece algo más
a esto
pero esta gráfica digamos que es en su
en ser graciosa
no es tan graciosa cuando la última
estadística nos dice que los
emprendedores son 70% más propensos a
sufrir enfermedades relacionadas con
salud mental
y ahí es donde nos damos
la
la realización de que la inteligencia
emocional necesaria no está siendo
suficiente para tener líderes que tienen
buena salud emocional
en el proceso yo dije que se puede hacer
frente a esto necesitamos líderes que
sean sanos en todo aspecto una persona
que está bien hace bien identifique
cuatro pasos el primero es que para
llevar una idea una realidad ustedes
tienen que tomar la iniciativa de servir
esto es claridad en el propósito del por
qué hago lo que hago pero eso no es
nuevo lo que quiero traer es la palabra
iniciativa porque es muy fácil
identificar que no funciona pero no es
tan fácil tomar la iniciativa de hacerlo
y una vez tomó la iniciativa hay que
tener claridad del proceso de servir yo
estoy al servicio de los demás al
servicio de una causa no estoy por mi
protagonismo propio y para mí eso es
como yo defino el liderazgo la capacidad
de alinear formas de pensar de sentir y
de actuar hacia un objetivo en común y
cuando digo alinear no quiere decir que
todo el mundo debe pensar sentir y
actuar de manera igual
la diversidad es lo que hace que una
idea se vuelva realidad pero es como en
nuestra diversidad de pensamiento y
actuar tenemos un objetivo en común
ahora en el segundo paso que descubrí ya
una vez el propósito está claro es
categorizar las responsabilidades
yo soy ingeniera y liderar proyectos de
educación trabajar en el foro económico
mundial reunirme con presidentes con
jefes de estado difícil entonces yo me
empecé a leer todos los libros que podía
de cómo ser mejor administradora y yo sé
por qué no estudié relaciones
internacionales porque no estudia
administración y en ese proceso de leer
todo lo que pude identifique
cuatro categorías hay que tener claridad
del objetivo de la operatividad y de la
comunicación y cuando se tienen esas
tres cosas hay que tener claridad de
cómo voy a liderar un equipo el objetivo
es saber para dónde voy la operatividad
es tener un plan flexible del cómo voy a
llegar allá la comunicación es tener la
capacidad de utilizar lenguaje verbal y
no verbal a las diferentes audiencias
con las que tengo que involucrar mi idea
y por último y más importante es que
tengo que aprender a trabajar con
personas con las con los seres más
complejos de ese planeta los seres
humanos
entonces esas categorías ya definidas
hay que definir los roles y en donde me
llega la tercera el tercer paso para mí
este objetivo la operativa de la
comunicación se traducen en estrategia
administración y representación la
estrategia es la capacidad de generar
una visión una misión y una dirección
la administración es la capacidad de
administrar recursos como el tiempo el
dinero
las personas los recursos humanos
administrar los riesgos administrar los
detalles y administrar prioridades que
se hace y que no se hace y cuando se
hace y la representación que es la
capacidad de transmitir un mensaje el
mensaje correcto en el momento correcto
a una reunión que involucra solamente
dos personas a una reunión que involucra
a todo el equipo a toda la empresa es
tener la capacidad de comunicar en una
conferencia lo que la idea y lo que la
empresa quiere lograr dar la cara ante
los medios de comunicación de una manera
efectiva
y es muy difícil y entonces ahora quiero
que ustedes empiecen a pensar en esta
estrategia como las personas que son muy
inteligentes son los líderes que tienen
todo súper claro la administración como
aquellos que son excelentes en la
ejecución los que no se les pasó en
detalle los que siempre están liderando
con el ejemplo porque son los primeros
en hacerlo quiero que piensen en la
representación en aquellos líderes que
son super inspiradores en aquellos
líderes que son super carismáticos y
entonces lo que quiero hacerles a
ustedes es un test ustedes creen que su
estilo de liderazgo está más en la
estrategia
ustedes creen que de pronto su jefe
está más entre la mitad él es muy bueno
sabiendo para dónde vamos pero también
lidera con el ejemplo entonces es muy
bien pero es perverso a la hora de
comunicarse sea de una reunión todo el
mundo termina dormido
o no es excelente excelente haciendo
pero no tiene ni idea para dónde vamos o
sea estamos trabajando como hormigas y
gallinas sin cabeza y al final no sabe
cómo motivarnos
hay otros muchos líderes se ubican aquí
donde están claros en la estrategia y
saben comunicarlo pero no tienen idea
cómo hacerlo
ahora la pregunta es por qué las ideas
fallan por una estadística muy
interesante bueno una de las muchas
razones 1 de cada 3 empleados dicen que
no toleran a su líder a su jefe y tres
de cada cinco creen que pueden hacer un
mejor trabajo que ellos
y eso obliga para también me imagino
profesores cabezas de familia los hijos
cuando yo o sea mamá no voy a hacer como
usted cuando yo sea profesor le voy a
mostrar como sea una clase
lo que eso termina pasando es que
estamos poniendo expectativas de que los
líderes tienen que estar en la mitad les
estamos pidiendo que tienen que tener el
cerebro de albert eisntein tienen que
tener la disciplina de un atleta
profesional tienen que tener el carisma
del dalai lama
y al final la perfección no existe la
perfección es la enemiga de la
excelencia y entonces quiero
compartirles un antídoto que yo descubrí
y para mí es la autenticidad si
hablábamos de manejar un equipo para mí
lo que más ha funcionado es la capacidad
de evaluar mis fortalezas y mis
debilidades de una manera objetiva
a aceptarlas y trabajar con ellas y
solamente cuando yo las aceptó y me
muestro tal y como soy me gano la
confianza de las personas a mi alrededor
mi equipo
los inversores mi familia
todos los que tienen que estar
involucrados para que esas ideas se
vuelvan realidad y en el momento en el
que yo soy auténtica
en el momento en el que yo me alineo con
mis valores con mis fortalezas y con mis
debilidades estoy haciendo una
invitación a que los demás lo hagan
conmigo y cuando uno empieza a trabajar
en un ambiente de autenticidad hay
confianza y empezamos a identificar y
pulir el talento empezamos a ver si el
objetivo común es este cuáles son tus
fortalezas tú qué tienes para ofrecer
y bueno empezamos a hacer un mapa de
talento la estrategia la representación
y la administración ya sabemos quiénes
están en la mesa en la mesa están las
personas que saben manejar la estrategia
muy bien pero que necesitan ser
complementadas por los que saben manejar
la administración muy bien y después
están los invitados que están en el
medio
así debería ser el nuevo liderazgo de
mapeo de habilidades donde todo el mundo
tiene claridad de su rol pero no
solamente funcional sino también dentro
de un equipo y que evolucionemos a un
liderazgo que no es protagónico ni
individual sino a un liderazgo en común
como un ecosistema un ecosistema de
liderazgo
donde la responsabilidad no recae en uno
sino en todos y donde todos estamos en
contra del problema no el problema en
contra de nosotros y con nosotros contra
nosotros
en este proceso de crear el ecosistema
de liderazgo auténtico yo descubrí que
no es tan fácil y que aunque estos pasos
que les compartió hoy
a propósito definir responso categorizar
las responsabilidades definir los roles
y generar todo lo que se necesita para
tener un ecosistema de liderazgo
auténtico es más fácil decirlo que
hacerlo y hay dos cosas que para mí son
fundamentales al momento de llevar una
idea una realidad y es que ustedes
tengan muy claro el precio que quieren
pagar por el sacrificio y la resistencia
que eso les va a implicar a ustedes
sacrificio a nivel personal
y profesional y resistencia que los va a
poner a ustedes a sus límites y en ese
proceso descubrí un poema que no es un
poema es un pensamiento de hecho por
theodore rooselvelt
que me ayuda a entender el primer paso
de tomar iniciativa la gloria pertenece
a aquellos que toman la iniciativa de
estar en la arena dentro de un estadio
es muy fácil ser espectador y decir así
no se hace yo soy mejor pero es el que
está en la arena quien está sufriendo y
quiero compartir eso que me ayudó tanto
con ustedes
no es el crítico quien cuenta ni el que
señala con el dedo al hombre fuerte
cuando tropiezan o el que indica en qué
cuestión es quien hace las cosas que
pudieran que pudiera que podría haberlas
hecho mejor
el mérito recae exclusivamente en el
hombre que se halla en la arena aquel
cuyo rostro está manchado de polvo sudor
y sangre el que lucha con valentía el
que se equivoca y falla el golpe una y
otra vez porque no hay esfuerzo sin
error y sin limitaciones
el que cuenta es el que de hecho lucha
por llevar a cabo las acciones el que
conoce los grandes entusiasmos las
grandes devociones el que agota sus
fuerzas en defensa de un propósito y una
causa noble el que si tiene suerte
saborea el triunfo de los grandes logros
y que si no la tiene y falla fracasa al
menos atreviéndose al mayor riesgo de
modo que nunca ocupará el lugar
reservado a esas almas frías que nunca
se atreven a llevar ninguna idea a
realidad
y espero que no sean ustedes muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]